السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره قالت مصادر ومحليه للجزيره ان
الجيش التركيه جدد قصفه بالمدفعيه
والطائرات المسيره مواقع ما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي سوريا وقال
مصدر تركي للجزيره
بين الامريكي والروسي لاخراج قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
رفعه وعين العرب لتفادي عمليه عسكريه
وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
بلاده مصممه على مكافحه مواصفه بالارهاب
ومنع وصوله الى تركيا واوضح اردوغان ان
تركيا لكل قدره على تحقيق انتصارات لا
يتوقعها احد بحسب تعبيره
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني وان القوات الروسيه
قصفت بالمدفعيه اكثر من 20 بلده شرقيه
اوكرانيا امس الثلاثاء واضاف الجيش
الاوكراني والنقوته دمرت 20 وحده اعتاد
عسكري ونفذ 16 غره على تمرزات القوات
الروسيه من جهتها التاهمت روسيا اوكرانيا
بتكثيفها هجماتها بالمسيرات على مطارات
داخل اراضيها
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
مستعده للعوده لمناقشه الضمانات العمليه
اذا كان الغرب مستعدا لذلك من جهته قال
المندوب الروسيه لدى الامم المتحده فاسيلي
نيفينسيا ان بلاده مستعده لجري مفاوضات مع
اوكرانيا يا طالما ان هدفها هو ازاله
الاسباب التي اجبت موسكو على اطلاق
عمليهها العسكريه الخاصه بتعبيره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الولايات المتحده
مخزونه اسلحه كافيه للاستمرار في مساعدته
اوكرانيا واضافه ان اسرع طريق للسلام
الاوكرانيا هو ان تسحب روسيا كل قواتها
رفعت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه قضيه اغتيال
الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله برصاصه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وقالت الشبكه في بياننا
هذه الخطوه تاتي بعد اجراء فريقها
القانوني تحقيقا كشف عن ادله جديده تظهر
بوضوح الناشرين وزملاءها تعرضوا لاطلاق
نار مباشر من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من جهده قال رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه يا ايرا لافيد انه لن يسمح
باستجواب اي من جنوده
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه لما كنتم طاب
توقعاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]